[Applause]
what new york lacked in crowds
it made up for in hope in the city that
normally welcomes the world
this year the message was to stay away
as new york reflected on a year
they would love to forget the few
invited were frontline workers
like baldwin who lost his twin brother
to covid19
the pair had worked together patrolling
times square for 19 years
his brother died before their 50th
birthday this summer
i was in my house with my family and i
felt something i said my
you know he my calvin just died they
said don't say
that and no more five minutes later the
doctor called i believe that if he would
have survived the first wave and caught
it the second way
he probably would have survived it
because the first way nobody didn't know
how to treat it
more than 25 000 new yorkers who brought
in
2020 lost their lives in the pandemic
even without the safety concerns there
felt little reason to celebrate
the turning of this year was marked with
grief
and grace the crowd stretched for nearly
20 blocks here this time last year but
like almost everything
coronavirus has cast a shadow over times
square
2020 will be studied by scientists and
historians in the years to come
but for the millions of new yorkers who
live the pandemic
it will be defined by moments of
personal loss
and resilience for calvin who works as
an emergency room doctor
and lost his grandfather to covet 19.
carrying out tests for guests at times
square
feels like a break i've seen things that
will give you nightmares for the rest of
your life
what makes our experience unique here in
new york city
is that we went through the worst of the
worst in march and april
but we also rebounded really quickly and
people of the world can look to us right
now especially in new year's eve
not just to see a ball drop but also new
yorkers coming together and realizing
with this small space we can work
together to
you know make a world you know more
hopeful and that's that's all i could
want for 2021.
the stroke of midnight will not cure
coronavirus
america is still battling a fierce
second wave
but donald trump struck a victorious
tone over vaccines
which are being rolled out woefully
slowly
in the face of great challenges this
year americans showed incredible grit
strength tenacity and resolve and
together we achieve truly historic
victories like
nobody ever thought possible
the crisis will long outlive the current
administration
but with 2020 in the rearview mirror
there is a sense here of immense hope
and relief
sally lockwood sky news new york